الخط الذي يفصل لبنان عن
إسرائيل متوتر في أفضل الأوقات
أكثر من أي وقت مضى ، لذا تبحث إسرائيل الآن عن
أنفاق تدعي أن فقاعته قد حفرت في
الأراضي الإسرائيلية ، حيث يراقب جندي عن
كثب من خلال منظاره على طاقم سي إن إن
على الجانب الآخر من  السياج
المعروف باسم الخط الأزرق منذ أن
بدأت العملية الإسرائيلية التي أطلق عليها اسم الدرع الشمالي قبل
أكثر من أسبوعين ، حيث
اكتشفوا ما لا يقل عن أربعة أنفاق.
حرب ، يتخذ الخطاب من
كلا الجانبين نبرة تهديد
الشهر الماضي ، حذر زعيم حزب الله حسن
نصر الله مقاتليه من
الرد إذا لم تضرب إسرائيل شيئًا ، أعني
أنك يجب أن تنظر إلى الرجل ، يا يلينا ، آصف علي ، يا
رجل ، شينوبي ، رجل ليهي
، كان لبنان وإسرائيل.  رسميًا في
حالة حرب منذ عام 1948 في صيف عام
2006 ، قاتلت إسرائيل وحزب الله
لأكثر من شهر ولكن منذ ذلك الحين كان هناك
احتمال لحدوث  ومع ذلك ، فإن حوادث مراكز التسوق
التي تثير صراعًا أوسع تلوح في الأفق دائمًا ، فنحن على حق على الحدود بين
إسرائيل ولبنان ، ولمجرد إعطائك
فكرة عن مدى قرب الجميع من بعضهم
البعض ، فهذا موقع للجيش اللبناني
هناك تحت تمويه
قواتنا الإسرائيلية وعلى حق  هناك قوات حفظ سلام تابعة للأمم المتحدة ،
قوات حزب الله ليست في
أي مكان يمكن رؤيتها ، فالكثير منهم مجرد
سكان محليين انضموا إلى المجموعة
على قمة التل ، التقينا بشابين
قالا إنهما جاءا للاستمتاع برؤية
هذا الرجل الذي عرّف عن نفسه ببساطة على
أنه أبو لهب قال لي الله.  يعطي
قوة للجيش والمقاومة نحن
معهم ، القوة المؤقتة للأمم المتحدة في
لبنان ، هل أنت
مكلف بتنفيذ
قرار مجلس الأمن الدولي رقم 7:01
الذي أنهى
أعمال القتال عام 2006 ولكنه نص أيضًا على أن
الجماعات المسلحة تعني حزب الله  يجب أن
ينزع سلاحه ،
لكن في المشهد السياسي المعقد في لبنان ،
تمكن حزب الله من الحفاظ
على ترسانته وبناء ترسانته وإرسال
مقاتليه لدعم  الجيش السوري في
حربه ضد المتمردين إسرائيل المنهكة
حزب الله يزداد قوة
بشكل يومي تقريبًا يرسل طائراته الحربية إلى
الأجواء اللبنانية
وقد ردت الحكومة اللبنانية على تقرير النفق
قائلة إن الجيش اللبناني قد تلقى
تعليمات باتخاذ جميع
الإجراءات اللازمة لتنفيذ القرار 1  7 0 1
والحفاظ على الهدوء على الحدود غير المتحضرة
المتحدث باسم أندريه من تينين يؤكد على
أهمية استمرار الهدوء على الرغم من
الانتهاكات التي ارتكبها كلا الجانبين كانت
انتهاكات من كلا
الجانبين لعام 1701 ، والمهم هو
التأكيد على أن هناك انتهاكًا
ولكنه سيحدث بالكامل.  كان الاستقرار في
جنوب لبنان الاستقرار نعم ولكن
خطوة واحدة خاطئة ويمكن أن يفجر بن ويدمان
سي إن إن جنوب لبنان